reject nation we finally got here with
the mandalorian season
two episode one chapter nine i believe
excited to check this out
obviously make sure to hit the subscribe
button and click that notification bell
to get notified when our next reaction
for the mandalorian is up hit that like
button too
a couple of things big thank you to eric
over at nerd chronic for editing this
video for us it was last minute today
where he decided yes i have time to edit
it so thank you buddy for doing that's a
big stress relief also we did get word
from some of our other reactor friends
that this episode's been having a hard
time getting up on youtube so i might
have to do some fine tuning to some of
the footage just as a little heads up
and last but not least full length
reaction
watch alongs where you sync up with the
time code will be over at our patreon
page this qualifies as
we cover many tv shows over at our
patreon these are
images of just a few to name but
thank you to everyone who's joined our
patreon page this month alone hopefully
you've been enjoying the content
over there anywho enough chit chat let's
swing into action
this is the way
very cool very cool
where is he gotham city
dude the trailer is all from the from
just this first time
and all
[Applause]
that's cheating
[Music]
give it to me now i will peel it off
your corpse
but we saw the trailer
oh
[Music]
oh stage dive
god the music yes yes
yes yeah you you want to punch my best
car steal go right ahead
[Music]
fibroblades
rock on
where are the drugs
now where is the mandalorian you know of
um
is he looking for boba fett
i've spent much time on tatooine i've
never seen a mandalorian he's totally
looking for him yeah
oh dang that's cold
where is moss pell go i'm told there's
one there
oh boy i haven't heard that name in a
while you want to see it
r5 bring the maps
seriously you just can't get good help
anymore i don't even know who to
complain to was that the unit luke was
supposed to buy
oh maybe sounds sounds kind of right in
my mind
because i know you still have that
speeder bike sure do of course she does
[Laughter]
those womp rats i've never actually seen
a womp rat
let me know in the comments if that was
a womp rat your marshall wears
mandalorian armor
see for yourself
oh my goodness gracious
what brings you here stranger that is
not him no
i think i know who it is though
is that timothy all about that's
everything sports
they gotta have headphones on i bet he
stole boba fett's armor
yeah it looks kind of ill-fitting on him
yeah if that's intentional he's taking
off his mask yeah he stole his armor he
stole his arm
yeah i've never met a real man delorean
oh where did you get the armor
bought off some jawas where'd you get
the accident jabba's got it off
boba we're gonna do this in front of the
kids
oh yeah he's done worse
yeah he's gonna he's gonna check it out
isn't he's gonna totally check it out
come on
oh never mind
the hell's going on something must be
like approaching that's huge
it's the creature in the starlight
monster
worms the spice
no maybe we can work something out
i'll take this off chill out
[Laughter]
it started after we got news of the
death star blowing up
that very night the mining collective
moved in our hates of vacuum and most
pell go became a slave camp
no oh damn
i would
my treasure bought me more than a full
water skin
it bought my freedom man they're really
bullying him up huh
yeah seriously
this goes to support my naked boba fett
theory
yeah he's still naked after all this
year yep he's walking around naked
he can't can't until he gets his armor
back
good didn't he use one blaster one shot
and it just went right
for the chest blade
wow he drove them all out of town
is that how that works
it's like a wolf pack yeah
i bet you tomorrow morrison's gonna show
up at the very end of this episode
they know about most people they know
how many sand people you killed
oh they raided our village i defended
the town
lower your voice oh
so many reaction shots of baby in this
episode
it lives in an abandoned sarlacc this
harlow
this thing is an abandoned store like
pit there it is if you eat the sarlacc
eat the sarlacc but boba
killed the sarlacc and then he ate it
wow
they might be open to some fresh
that was great i love that you think it
will work
it better joining forces is their only
hope
hope
i gotta say god i love this grounded
spotlight
look dealing with like politics
prejudices
yeah damn they threw down on those too
they're like six of them
that's an explosive take it easy it was
an accident
okay what do you want to do it was an
accident this is just like remember the
titans
it's gonna be great oh please don't let
him die
this dragon's just gonna come out and
take one
swoop the single file line was a mistake
i love how they really actually give
like a tense horror vibe
this was a bad idea oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
whoa what they shoot the cameras right
there you see the letter boxes
oh my god they shot us with different
cameras
oh well he's like an imax camera or
something
maybe oh my goodness
wow this was not meant to be watched on
a computer
meant to be watched in a theater near
you
wow that is terrifying now you guys are
making me mad
oh great shot dude that has insane
effects
oh that's gotta be acid right
oh
[Music]
i don't think it's dead me either
we got too much more time left in the
episode it's picking us off like warp
rats
is like the word of the day
that's great oh my god this looks so
cool
shoot it in the throat
ugh i've got an idea get its attention
nice good shot good shot what are you
gonna do
[Laughter]
you're gonna let yourself get swallowed
by this thing
to prove that boba could live through it
[Music]
oh what a shot look at how beautiful
this looks
now the raiders and the people just
start killing each other
i hope our paths cross again as do i
season three
there it is okay our disney plus account
did not just zoom in
it's interesting though slightly
confused now they shot out with a
different camera
yeah that's him that's gotta be boba
that's gotta be
[Music]
all right let's chit chat wow okay whoa
there's one thing i really do want to
check first
i got nervous to say it in case i got a
wrong episode one
pod racer is that the same one that um
cobb has i mean maybe it was like
fashioned out of the engine or something
like that i think it's the same one cobb
has
it could be let's go back to that moment
maybe somebody found it as junk and like
converted it
because it seems like the car i mean it
looks yeah it looks like it looks like
it's part of his
right yeah looking looking at his pot
racer
one from here a bit yeah it looks like
it could be just in really poor repair
and they just like
like it's one it's one part of it yeah
yeah it's like they melted a chair onto
the side
boba fett's outfit and darth vader's pot
racer
guys that is great this guy is the
thrift shop
galaxy because i look like him i'm like
but i thought there were two
yeah i think that's it that would be
pretty sweet i mean it that
it was on tattoo weed yeah yeah there's
definitely a lot of connective tissue
that support this theory way to go for
cobb and yeah that was definitely both
it was like playing that footage back
though of looking at uh boba fett right
here he just looks so different than
tamora morrison
like they really did a number on his
makeup there they made him all
apocalypse now
no they really did yeah i didn't even
recognize tomorrow morrison's face
doesn't have eyebrows
you know it's like they're like burnt
off he's scarred up yeah and he's all
backlit and he's like
finally i can now get access to my boba
fett armor
i could never go into the town before
but now i can go into the town
now i won't have to be banished i
thought overall it was a great episode
i love the tone the mood of it of course
combining the western
flair with a bit of that monster horror
vibe throughout i mean that last 10
minutes man they really threw down for
production design there
the monster effects look so grand so
beautiful and to do that in broad
daylight
like not working within shadows is very
tough that's very hard usually you have
to have a lot of shadows in order to
make it work and sure they have like a
lot of dirt covering the crate dragon
but at the same time like those close-up
shots were kind of terrifying
to be honest you know yeah well and with
the bump in quality i don't know if they
shot it on like a legit imax camera or
like a digital imax or something
emulating that but with that added
layer of quality it's that much more
impressive to have these big yeah broad
daylight cg effects that really
are for this episode movie caliber like
we're about to
we're going to see dune next year do
something similar yeah you know yeah i
love the opening of it
seeing the gamoreans uh come be used as
like slave gladiator like battle
this mission that mando's on i'm not
sure exactly
why why is he looking specifically for
this mandalorian though for boba fett
you know
why specifically him did they make that
clear is that tying into the answers
possibly linking to kamino
uh considering boba fett's history
that's like the best guess that we've
had
that theory for a while of why boba fett
would be coming in
but they didn't make that specifically
clear here it's a good standalone
episode it really was a hardcore western
episode
okay they started to pluck timothy
olyphant as his cobbed character
to be another cowboy-like character and
i love the use of him with the boba fett
i look like a child random boba fett
outfit
yeah you're so skinny yeah well and two
like the way his outfit is colored and
everything he looks like an old-timey
like cowboy would be the lead on an old
series a western show
and uh actually we were remarking on the
episode the bartender guy
is an actor from deadwood oh crazy yeah
so there's like little connective tissue
there with timothy elephant and being
western vibes
who was john linguazamo he was the
mobster with the one eye
he was running the fight oh that was
john leguizamo
yeah left tied up and and ostensibly to
be eaten
didn't even recognize his voice he has
such a i recognized timothy allah's
voice before i recognized john liquid
zamasu
i was sitting there during that one
going this has to be somebody notable i
i feel like the voice is familiar and i
just can't place it and i think for him
he was probably putting something on
okay okay uh yeah i mean he was a great
character
no baby other didn't do much but they
did a lot to remind you of baby yoda in
here throughout
of so many just reaction shots of baby
yoda right away from going to pelly
motto
at the very beginning of it you know
you're immediately thinking of that
episode
was that's that's called the gunslinger
episode five of uh
amanda lauren meets the young guy yeah
tying it back in that makes sense
especially with boba fett showing up at
the end of that episode to
get grab fennec shan's body tie back in
fully this
this was great you know it's like a lot
of times i mean people will often
complain about nostalgia use in star
wars in the first episode they're going
back to tattooing right away but what
they did with it
with this town of mos peligo with the
tuscan raiders having kind of like a
you know that that tradition the way how
episode four of mandalorian
was a bit of that traditional western
magnificent seven vibe this isn't quite
that but it does feel very traditional
in the sense that these townspeople got
to work together
take down this common thread form this
piece this unity together it's very star
wars-esque as well giving the tuscan
raiders some real personality here i
thought
was awesome and then also giving uh you
know
taking a look at a new town and watching
that even after
the second death star blew up seeing
that
hey you know there were people who
really did take advantage doesn't mean
evil was completely vanquished obviously
we know that you know seeing like the
way how
people were taken advantage of during
the time of celebration on tatooine
uh was pretty harrowing you know i
really enjoyed that flashback i really
enjoyed seeing the thing with him with
the jawas and getting the boba fett
armor was really cool
this episode did kind of everything i
love about the mandalorian in general
like it didn't
i think get too weighed down by all this
stuff we know is coming to the season
which i'm glad about it
suckered me in with the western v like
after a while i was appreciating how
much it was fleshing out the world like
yeah okay here's the fallout of the
collapse of the death star and
everything and here's
interpersonal relationships between two
tribes that are nearby one another and
clearly have
strong feelings about each other so it's
kind of fleshing out the universe
but also zeroing in on a specific
obstacle to get us to the next step
which is very you know
western i'm here looking for somebody
that someone is
close by but i gotta figure something
else out before you know i get to that
and even these shots of just
transcribing you know instead of them
riding horses through the desert they're
riding these speeder bikes through the
desert
and uh yeah just like all the use of
detail the music i thought was
amazing throughout the episode the
effects and everything and yeah the way
it built up to that showdown it almost
felt like
i didn't have a problem with the episode
where he teams up with cara dune in the
previous season and they fight the
you know the big stat or whatever yeah
but uh
uh this one felt like a more natural
iteration of
that where it's like okay here's the
conflict that directly involves this
town and they're not
quite organized enough to take care of
it so i'm gonna help them and come up
with a strategy and we're gonna involve
everybody
but it felt i don't know just like a
more natural iteration of that and a
more
even representation of everyone's
involvement i guess
i hate to interrupt you please while
john's been talking
i've been scanning that moment where he
first shows up in a town
and uh that extra no that i don't
i think that's sam what it looks like
sam whitworth is that sound
i don't know i mean it's kind of on our
screen recording it's a little blurry
but it looks like sam wouldn't work
because that first time he rolled into
town and that extra like they looked at
him i was like
i wonder if that's somebody specific
well i mean the way they were showing
all those people in the town i was like
one of these people has to be like a big
cam you're like who is she this is asian
lady the mom of someone
you know like sam woodward a cameo in
every episode
i mean but yeah you know he's been a big
part of
the star wars additional canon from like
force unleashed to darth maul and
he did another thing it's not coming to
mind but it looks like sam wilbur
confirmed for us that that sound where
we're below this really was a great
episode i think the effects were awesome
i love the addition of cobb i thought he
was a great character in here
teasing for what's to come and i love
how you know you think you're just gonna
swing right into
um pulse pounding oh we gotta find the
answers for the child right away but i
love how this feels very traditional
this feels like the early part of uh the
first few seasons of mandalori and where
it wasn't as serialized but you know
it's gonna tie in
significantly because of the fact of you
know you got boba fett at the end
and such and all this additional
information but there's so much more to
come i loved it
thought it was great action was top
notch it was perfect
i i don't really i don't have an issue
with it you know
katano at the dark saber we're going to
know no patience no pacing
we'll just google later to find out that
was time over anyway guys thanks so much
for being here
hey subscribe to real rejects click that
notification bell to get notified when
our next reaction from the mandalorian
is up full length reaction watching long
overdue patreon
hit that like button yada yada yada
leave your thoughts down below see you
guys soon